[Musica]
ricordo ancora e confesso che ancora
oggi provo un po' di ansia le mie prime
settimane da matricola all
giurisprudenza Padova Quando dopo la
lezione di diritto privato della mattina
una mezz'oretta circa in un'aula Ederle
gremita di matricole che di lì a pochi
mesi per la maggior parte si sarebbero
trasferite altrove si faceva a gara per
trovare un posto per studiare in una di
quelle biblioteche antichissime che ci
sono al Bo dal pavimento di
scricchiolante e piene di libri che ti
facevano sentire già un avvocato meglio
un mezzo avvocato ancora meno perché
solo dopo aver fatto Diritto Privato sia
mezzi
avvocati ma dopo aver assaporato questa
sensazione di importanza in queste
biblioteche davanti al mitico e
leggendario libro di Manuale di Diritto
Privato il Trabucchi Che forse tutti
avrete sentito nominare
ho mi sono confrontata con quella che
oggi definiremo una barriera linguistica
ovvero Io leggevo le parole ma ne capivo
sì e no due tre di cinque che leggevo In
sostanza non capivo quasi niente adesso
dopo 40 anni che faccio
l'avvocato parlo anche sempre quasi da
avvocato anche quando vado a fare la
spesa ma quando mi è stato chiesto di
fare questo intervento sul tema
dell'eredità sotto un profilo giuridico
mi sono venuta in mente come un istante
dejà vu le parole classiche testamento
eredità legato legittimari e sono andata
a vedere nel vocabolario di base se
queste parole siano di uso comune e le
ho trovate e quindi ho pensato di oggi
pomeriggio di utilizzare e di farvi
conoscere se non le conoscete già tre
parole che io definirei di un lessico
ereditario moderno perché sono parole
quelle che vi che vi spiegherò che non
sono contenute nel codice civile che è
del
1942 perché si riferiscono a situazioni
che erano all'epoca inimmaginabile E vi
parlerò di testamento biologico di Trust
dopo di noi e di eredità digitale
l'abbiamo già sentita questo pomeriggio
in una pregevole
lezione Però sotto un profilo diverso
verso etico mentre io cercherò di capire
cosa significhi veramente eredità
digitale da un punto di vista di
trasmissione dei diritti mi dovrete
consentire però adesso di rubarvi 30
secondi per definire per darvi due
definizioni una di eredità in generale E
una di testamento l'eredità cos'è
l'eredità è l'insieme dei diritti e
degli obblighi trasmissibili tenete a
mente questa parola che un soggetto ha
nel momento in cui passa a miglior vita
il nostro sistema della delle
successioni prevede un Unicum si parla
di asse ereditario l'asse era una moneta
romana e la parola asse significa intero
Quindi tutti i diritti trasmissibili
passano da un soggetto ai suoi eredi
senza soluzioni di continuità non ci
devono essere situazioni di incertezza
sulla titolarità dei diritti Quindi il
nostro sistema prevede vede che in
mancanza di testamento il sia la legge
stessa a stabilire chi siano gli eredi
tant'è che se non ci fossero eredi entro
il sesto grado sarà lo stato l'ultimo e
necessario
erede testamento il codice civile
definisce il testamento in una maniera
io direi quasi poetica è testamento
l'atto revocabile con cui taluno dispone
delle sue sostanze per il in cui avrà
cessato di vivere quindi la parola morte
non viene
utilizzata cosa cosa devo sottolineare
in questo che il testamento è l'unico
atto di ultima volontà che che consente
che viene consentito dalla legge per una
persona e dispone solo per la la vita
dopo la morte cioè la sorte delle
sostanze delle proprie sostanze dopo la
morte passiamo adesso alla prima delle
tre parole che vi
voglio indicare stasera e spiegare la
prima è testamento biologico si collega
al testamento ma in realtà non è un
testamento per la la vita dopo la morte
ma è una manifestazione di
volontà per delle situazioni particolari
che possono accaderci durante la vita il
legislatore italiano nel 2017 ha
disciplinato il diritto di ciascuno di
noi di ehm decidere e di anticipare il
consenso ai trattamenti sanitari a delle
terapie particolare a degli interventi
chirurgici consentendo a ciascuno di
esprimere in anticipo nominando anche un
soggetto fiduciario che può non essere
un familiare Ma che è e che avrà il
compito di avere di tenere i rapporti
con le con le strutture sanitarie con i
medici in modo tale da assicurare che la
volontà espressa da una persona
maggiorenne capace di intendere di
volere per il caso in cui non lo non
potrà esprimere un consenso
informato in caso di malattia o di
incidente venga rispettata perché è
importante questa legge non solo da un
punto di vista ovviamente etico e di di
riconoscimento di di un diritto dalla
persona di autodeterminarsi ma anche da
un punto di vista formale Perché Perché
il testamento biologico può essere reso
anche nelle forme non tradizionali
quelle che noi conosciamo per il
testamento postmortem che deve valere
postmortem per questo c'è solo la
scrittura di pugno o l'atto notarile nel
mentre il testamento leat disposizione
Anticipa di trattamento Questo è il
termine tecnico del
per altrimenti detto testamento
biologico biotestamento le data possono
essere anche raccolte con
videoregistrazioni o o con o con altri
strumenti tecnici che consentono alle
persone
gravemente disabili di esprimere il
consenso per le persone che invece
stanno bene il modo per farlo è andare
in Comune compilare un Format e
consegnarlo al comune Ma quello che è
molto importante è che mentre noi ci
compiacciamo di questa legge del 2017
perché è stato veramente un passo avanti
anche di civiltà Oserei dire ma e e
soprattutto perché il legislatore ha
recepito anche la funzione della
tecnologia ma mi sono chiesta se visto
che tutti noi abbiamo oggi abbiamo
sentito parlare poi di di di di che nel
mondo ci sono più iPhone che persone e
abbiamo tutti quanti nei nostri
smartphone o Smart watches le
applicazioni salute nelle quali si può
si può anche indicare non solo il
proprio stato di salute ma anche se si
se si sono da date disposizioni
anticipate di trattamento oppure la
donazione degli organi Ecco mi sono
domandata se visto che queste
applicazioni sono accessibili senza
chiavi di accesso ai primi soccorritori
mi sono domandata Se questo fosse
sufficiente come forma
per garantire che la nostra volontà
venisse rispettata ora allo stato della
legislazione italiana direi di no Noi
possiamo Certamente implementare questa
app per agevolare il lavoro dei
soccorritori che però dovranno sempre
andare a chiedere ai Cioè a consultare
la banca dati nazionale dei delle
disposizioni anticipate di trattamento
dei donatori per poter assicurarsi che
quella fosse veramente la nostra
volontà in America invece nel già nel
2016 Apple e Donate Life America avev
hanno annunciato ai
aigli utenti di iPhone che potevano
direttamente con pochi Tap dare queste
disposizioni di donazione per la
donazione degli organi dei degli occhi e
dei tessuti Quindi io confido
che questa evoluzione ci sarà anche in
Italia naturalmente richiede un accordo
tra il Apple e la banca dati perché sono
andata a vedere e in metà ottobre del
2023 quindi qualche giorno fa il sito
del Ministero della Salute diceva che ci
sono ben
7980 pazienti in lista d'attesa per un
trapianto mi sono domandata se una forma
disintermediare di prestazione del
consenso alla donazione degli orgi non
potrebbe anche aiutare a eliminare
questa lista
d'attesa la seconda parola di cui voglio
parlarvi è Trust dopo di noi Trust cos'è
il Trust il Trust Penso che tutti quanti
ormai anche questo più o meno abbiamo
L'abbiamo sentita questa parola è un
istituto di diritto anglosassone nasce
in Inghilterra nel 1500 un istituto che
noi non conosciamo perché la nostra
nostra tradizione giuridica e di
impianto romanistico che in Italia è un
contratto che in Italia è considerato
legittimo Perché l'Italia ha ratificato
la convenzione dell'ia nel 1985 Ma come
accade spesso in Italia non abbiamo una
legge c'è un paradosso Perché l'Italia
non ha una legge che disciplina il Trust
per cui chi vuole fare un Trust deve per
forza scegliere una legge straniera che
lo Disciplini con dei limiti ovviamente
di diritto interno Come si dice mi
spiego se uno volesse istituire un Trust
scegliendo la legge inglese che non
prevede La legittima perché in tal modo
pensa di eludere le norme invece
italiane di applicazione necessaria che
impediscono Cioè non consentono di tra
virgolette in maniera volgare dico
diseredare cioè non attribuire una quota
dell'eredità alla moglie al coniuge o ai
figli Beh questo non lo potrebbe fare
attraverso un Trust il Trust
brevissimamente appunto è un contratto
con cui una persona che si chiama
settlor segrega una parte dei suoi beni
o tutti come vuole e li intesta
fiduciariamente un'altra persona che si
chiama trasti e questi beni il trasti
non di divent proprietario ma li deve
amministrare Per uno scopo ben preciso
indicato dal settlor e nell'interesse
dei beneficiari cos'è la cos'è il Trust
dopo di noi che mi
ha che che di cui vorrei parlarvi il
Trust dopo di noi è un altro passo
avanti del legislatore italiano che nel
ha consentito e per la prima volta la
parola Trust appare in un testo testo
normativo italiano di Che disciplina dei
diritti civili ha istituito il Trust
dopo di noi perché per consentire ai
genitori o alle persone di che
accudiscono
disabili gravi
di di assicurare dopo la loro morte ai
ai ai disabili una vita serena in cui il
patrimonio venga amministrato da da
persone scelte direttamente dai genitori
o dalla o dalle persone che accudiscono
il che accudiscono la persona disabile
questo Trust Infatti è destinato a
chiudersi a concludersi con la morte
della persona
disabile vengo adesso alla terza parola
la terza parola ne avete già sentito
parlare oggi pomeriggio eredità digitale
come ho detto quello di cui
io quello che cercherò di dirvi è Qual è
lo stato della parte
dell'interpretazione su da un punto di
vista giuridico su cosa sia l'eredità
digitale cos'è il patrimonio digitale e
come viene trasmesso Allora di
patrimonio digitale non c'è una
definizione normativa gli studiosi la
dottrina come la chiamiamo noi hanno
cercato di dare una definizione cos'è il
patrimonio digitale quel insieme di dati
e informazioni che riguardano la vita di
una persona che sono affidati allo
spazio
elettronico e che vengono utilizzati
attraverso i file il tweet le
chat i profili
media si parla di patrimonio online e
patrimonio offline il patrimonio offline
patrimonio digitale offline è quello
contenuto nelle CH è la chiavetta il PC
gli smartphone Ma sono dei supporti
fisici ma quello che è veramente
interessante su questi non c'è non c'è
discussione il
mio smart watch se muoio verrà le mie
figlie Spero che non litigheranno per
averlo
Ma sarà trasmesso a loro il diritto di
proprietà Sarà trasmesso a loro ma
quello che è veramente interessante da
capire e da indagare è il patrimonio on
cioè tutti i dati che non sono su un
supporto fisico ma sono in un Cloud
oppure per il cui accesso è necessario
avere la chiave di accesso Allora è del
2005 il primo caso in America di
controversia giudiziaria riguardante
l'accesso ai dati i genitori di un
marine di 20 anni morto in Iraq avevano
chiesto da yaho che era il provider con
il quale il ragazzo aveva l'account di
posta elettronica di rendere accessibile
la posta elettronica del figlio dopo la
morte e yau oppose un rifiuto perché
perché le condizioni generali di
contratto prevedevano che alla morte del
dell'utente
il alla morte dell'utente il l'account
venisse bloccato o addirittura
cancellato in quel caso il tribunale in
America consentì per ragioni affettive
ai genitori di accedere quindi ordinò ad
yaho di accedere di consentire l'accesso
all'account del figlio ma sono passati
20 anni quasi da allora e ripeto una
normativa certa non c'è per cui noi ogni
volta che abbiamo una degli eredi che
vogliono accedere al contenuto digitale
che era di proprietà del de cuius
debbono rivolgersi al tribunale perché
appunto la maggior parte delle
condizioni contrattuali non prevede la
possibilità di subentrare nel contratto
Quindi quelli che adesso vedete come
account commemorativi che sono cose
recenti non sono account nei quali gli
eredi possono
accedere in Italia abbiamo avuto tre
casi tre Tribunali si sono occupati
della della domanda di altrettanti eredi
che volevano contro Apple perché
volevano accedere agli account di posta
elettronica ed evitare la distruzione e
la la perdita dei dati anche in questo
caso il
i tribunali tutti i tribunali hanno
acconsentito
all'accesso ai dati ma quello che è
interessante al di là della dello scopo
pratico che è stato raggiunto è capire
per per un giurista su che basi
giuridiche è stato consentito l'accesso
e questo è molto interessante perché la
base giuridica è stato il vincolo
familiare Qui si aprirebbe un mondo ma
il mio tempo sarebbe già scaduto per cui
chi chi è la famiglia per perché
comunque questi Tribunali han detto
Siete familiari probabilmente in quel
caso lì l'avevano dimostrato e quindi
potete accedere Ma perché Perché il de
cuius non aveva esplicitato il divieto
di accesso e questa Secondo me è la vera
novità il codice della Privacy italiano
l'articolo 2 così come è stato
modificato Dopo l'entrata in vigore nel
2018 della del regolamento europeo sulla
privacy prevede espressamente che
ciascuno di noi abbia il diritto
di vietare l'accesso ai propri dati on
dopo la sua morte ma se questo è vero
Allora io debbo concludere o posso
concludere vedremo perché la
giurisprudenza è in evoluzione ed è una
materia che si sta studiando ora io
posso concludere che se anche ritengo
che il mio patrimonio di digitale sia un
eh un diritto
trasmissibile trova sempre limite e
condizionamento nel fatto che io stesso
lo voglia trasmettere io stessa voglio
farmi conoscere attraverso i Virtual gz
anche dopo la mia morte A me piace
pensare che questo Trend della
giurisprudenza si consolidi e anche
della della normativa e che ci possa
essere davvero per ciascuno di noi il
diritto di avere una sfera assolutamente
riservata una il diritto all'oblio in
eterno
Grazie